we have a voicemail the voicemail is
very very interesting and it is about
someone who appears to be quite taken
with producer Pat our voicemail number
is two one nine two david p let's take a
listen to what this caller had to say oh
god please don't shut the show down
because it means because i made these
very erotic and seductive phone calls to
you david especially view Patrick please
I apologize don't shut this show down
because of me please I'm sorry I'm a big
fan of for you this we you beautiful
Patrick yeah quite an admirer Pat that
you have here how am I supposed to feel
about this I think you should feel fine
I mean the show's not gonna get shut
down because your appearance is so
distracting to some viewers that they
can't help but leave us erotic
voicemails or whatever it is the caller
suggesting it seems like this person was
more enamored with you over the years
and maybe now they're swaying in my
direction oh the attention is completely
off of me at this point with this viewer
are you relieved uh it's not a relief or
jealousy but it is I'm merely observing
what it is that's taking place and it is
endlessly fascinating that's for sure on
the bonus show today Alabama and a
particular Alabama Church wants to
create its own police force we'll talk
about that the average distance from any
point in the us to the closest forest
has increased significantly since
nineteen ninety why we will explore that
and a man who engaged in sexual hate
crimes involving a disabled teen will
serve zero zero jail time all of those
stories and more on the bonus show david
pakman.com slash membership to sign up
the coupon code is available it's I
voted 17